hi I'm patty Kim whether you trying to
skate warm in the deep freeze of winter
stay cool when it's absolutely boiling
outside the summer heating and cooling
your home offers you some of the best
and biggest opportunities to cut down on
energy waste and save yourself some
money but it does require a couple of
key things running your cooling and
heating systems efficiently and making
sure that your home is properly
insulated from the outside elements
here's how you do it your house is
heating and cooling systems can add up
to forty-five percent of your utility
bill and have a tremendous impact on the
environment a good place to start
improving is right here with the brain
of the system the thermostat setting the
temperature lower in winter will help
save you energy in fact about three
percent less energy for every single
degree you drop likewise in some are
raising the thermostat will also help
save you energy and don't forget this is
just as important change those furnace
filters monthly keeping the home comfy
isn't all about setting the temperature
the outside elements may be creeping in
without you even knowing it about a
third of outside air enters through
floors walls and ceilings small cracks
and joints allow cold air in during
winter and air conditioned air out in
summer
to cut down on wasted energy seal
exposed air paths around plumbing
electrical wiring and ducting that
traverse walls with or foam now
you'll want to make sure you pay extra
special attention to areas that separate
the exterior from the interior ie doors
doors are a natural culprit front doors
doors that open to the garage their
major source of heat loss for your home
now to avoid that ensure the tightest
seal possible around your doorway check
and see what your weather stripping
looks like if you don't have any you
definitely want to add some stripping
and if you do check for wear and tear
and at the very least replace the worn
out sections and closing doors to unused
rooms is also a helpful thing because it
helps reduce the amount of space you
have to heat and cool that fireplace
that keeps your living room cozy in
winter can let out up to eight percent
of your holdings warm or cool air make
sure the dampers are closed when not in
use
it's great to have the sunlight
streaming in and the beautiful views
that large windows can offer you but
this is an area where you can lose a
significant amount of energy but you can
minimize heat loss by up to fifty
percent simply by installing storm
shutters over your windows closing
curtains & window shades at night will
help keep the warmth in during the
colder months while closing them during
the day and summer will reflect the
sun's rays and keep things cool and if
you're renovating installing new windows
with the Energy Star label that will
reduce your heating & cooling costs by
at least fifteen percent the key to
having uniform temperatures in the house
good insulation the fact of the matter
is most houses aren't insulated well
enough for their climate that's
especially true if your house was built
before 1980 adding more insulation to
your crawlspace or attic can create
energy savings year-round there are lots
of choices when it comes to insulation
but recycled cotton cellulose and soy
bean foam earn high marks for their
eco-friendliness we've offered you a few
tips today to help make your home more
comfortable and efficient but that said
every home is unique to get the best
results for your home call your local
utility company and schedule an energy
audit changes that you make today will
go a long long way towards saving you
money and the planet that's it for now
I'm patty Kim we'll see you next time
to find out how well sealed your home is
click on the link below to take the quiz